hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
September 26
202222
what's going on how are ya
I gotta record this on my phone
I gotta record this on my phone because
once again
the goddamn [ __ ] computer isn't
working
it doesn't recognize the extra
GarageBand does not recognize the
external device I love how it says that
when it puts that on the screen and I
read that I go that's obviously not for
me
right what am I supposed to do with that
what am I a [ __ ] scientist the
external device
what could that be the keyboard the
mouse the microphone the the the the
[ __ ] the the interface
what do you mean you don't recognize it
are you having cognitive issues
do you do you would you care to to
expand
on that little [ __ ] window that keeps
popping up so now I gotta you know
whatever whatever
who gives a [ __ ] you know who gives a
[ __ ] this is just
this is what life has become
life has become you know trying to make
sure your device is fast enough to run
with everybody else's device
and then just throwing it out
even though it still works because
nobody wants it anymore because it's not
fast enough
what if what the [ __ ] do you think all
these laptops end up
where do they all end up they just got
them stacked up somewhere
um and all of these [ __ ] phones I
guess the new the latest iPhone just
came out
it just never ceases to amaze me listen
to people talking about the latest cell
phone and all the things that it can do
two they have this new thing on it right
if you just touch a letter like the
letter like touches your finger back
it's like creepy at first but that was a
bad example what the [ __ ] I don't know
what they're doing I don't know what
these [ __ ] nerds want next
um
I can't tell you I forgot my phone when
I was out in Phoenix
I left it in the hotel room
and um
I went out for a couple hours
and um
because I didn't have a phone and
everybody else had a phone that's when I
suddenly realized like how much I'm on
my phone
this is really not new information but
uh underrated leaving the house without
your phone
um
it is kind of nuts like you remember
that anybody else old like me like when
you left the house back in the day you
would just it would no one knew where
you were
yeah I am driving to work like that was
it there was just like this this
like
black hole
when you got to the house so you got the
office like no one could be in touch
with you
that's it you had your own little
[ __ ] world
you had your own little time
you know if you got out of the house you
decided to get a cup of coffee you sat
down you just had it
you just sat there sipping it
you know you weren't staring at a device
you know you were looking around
you see another attractive woman over
there she's looking at you you look back
right this gives you half a smile
so you bring your eyebrows up a little
bit and then she nods the next thing you
know you're sitting with her and then
you begin an affair and you ruin your
marriage
you know do you think there's less it's
weird this it should be like less Affair
if there wasn't social media I think
there would be less
like fights
just less human interaction
less opportunities for us to hurt
ourselves Maybe
I don't know I'm not talking about I had
a [ __ ] guys weekend man I went out to
uh Phoenix Arizona
with the one and only Paul verzi
and uh some wonderful people from all
things comedy
and uh we did uh we did a live gig on
the Great Lawn outside of where the
Phoenix Arizona
Cardinals the Arizona Cardinals play
and we did a we did a live anything
better where we did our picks for the
week
and um
my God we had a [ __ ] great time we
just had a great time we did that
and then we hung out a little bit but we
were going golfing in the morning we had
like a 7 30 tea time or 7 15 something
like that so I made the smart move I
smoked a little cigar and then I was
just like
all right I'm going to bed and uh went
to bed
and we got up the next day and we played
golf and uh
I don't know I I actually kind of
enjoyed it I I did I do have like like
after six holes I just can't
you know I always start saying like is
this the eighth hole that we're like no
no it's only the seventh yeah just I
just start like wanting to get out at
night like get out of there I just um
I'm over it
[Music]
like playing 18 holes of golf is just I
mean that is that is a [ __ ]
commitment
um
but I do enjoy playing
and I do enjoy watching people going
through that care about the game going
through the [ __ ] that they go through
when they're playing it it's kind of
funny because they're always just like
the first couple of holes
everybody's you know they're trying they
want you to because they love the game
so much they want you to play so like
dude look at this the grass is beautiful
man this is what it's all about we're
gonna be smoking sticks by the fourth
hole you know [ __ ] look at those you
know beautiful mountains you know we
were in Arizona they were all 100 right
then by like the second and third hole
that's when you start hearing the first
ah [ __ ]
ing
can start losing it
it's almost like a relationship you know
the first two holes it's oh you're so
beautiful I don't know what my life was
without you you know and then by holes
like four five six it's like hey can you
do me a favor and not leave your your
shoes over there I'm not yelling I'm not
yelling I'm just look I'm not yelling
I'm just I'm just saying you know and
then by like the ninth hole you know
you're a couple kids in
and he's just like can you just have my
[ __ ] back one [ __ ] time I'll go to
your mother's go to your mothers I'm
sure you guys will have a grand old time
talking about me
that's what it's like golfing
with people and uh
there was actually a minimal amount of
that but there was definitely like
people get like
they get so [ __ ] mad and it's funny
to me because I have such a temper and I
lose my [ __ ] over absolutely nothing but
there's just something about the game of
golf that is just so inherently silly
you know like I love when somebody's on
the Green
and they're like
they're like lining they're trying to
read the grain
I mean does it ever go in all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] down and then they walk to
the other side of the hole and then
they're doing that and everybody's just
standing around just going oh my God
just hit the [ __ ] thing we all know
you're getting a bogey it's not going in
and then they hit it and it doesn't go
anywhere and then they just gotta sort
of stand there and look at it like
like
like the Earth doesn't make sense but
the way they were looking at the Earth
did
right
I also loved like the little [ __ ]
that little thing where they you know
the I call it the litter box you know
what they do when they're like before
they they go to do a putt they get all
like hunched over and then they do like
they lift up the right foot set it down
left foot set it down they peek Pat like
they were in a [ __ ]
like a kitty cat a little kitty cat move
right and it's just so [ __ ] funny to
watch some guy
doing that you know with some big gaudy
like gold bracelet hanging off his
[ __ ] ridiculously tanned arms
old old guy hairy arms
it's almost like there's like a like a
buffer
you know is what the there's so much
hair and it's like there's only a little
bit of black left so I'm like
well that white thing and they do a
little pit pet Pit pet Pit pet Pit pad
and then right as they hit it they know
it's not going in and then they just do
that gesture with the putter like oh
come on
this is
um
so I've decided that
uh I will play golf
when people ask me but I'm never buying
clubs and I'm Never Keeping score and
I'm just going to go out there what I'm
really out there for is to joke around
with my friends
and make people laugh
and then just sit there and learn about
myself while I watch other people losing
their [ __ ] and I just go like you know
what I do that when I'm in traffic or I
do that when uh
you know my [ __ ] old ass truck starts
leaking again in the garage I need to
learn to control
I don't know why I don't know what it is
about golf like golf is supposed to make
you [ __ ] nuts and I am a [ __ ]
lunatic over absolutely nothing when I
walk around but I go out on the golf
course I can't even tell you how much I
just don't
just don't give a [ __ ]
you know like the only thing that really
got my blood going was these [ __ ]
[ __ ] behind us
I guess they thought we were playing
slow and this guy as we were driving off
he tried to hit his second shot onto the
onto the uh the green and he had to yell
four
and I I didn't really give a [ __ ] but
the guy I was with was like dude what
the [ __ ] he shouldn't be doing that that
was the first that's the first time I
sort of like woke up because it was like
an actual opponent as opposed to sitting
there like being in the same mindset you
have when you're like folding your
laundry
you know
you know that Melancholy there's
something about the laundromat that just
is just depressing
you know having to wash your clothes
with other people
and then seeing their lives and their
[ __ ] clothes
you know
sometimes you just see a dad or a mom
and you look at the kid you just feel
like that kid doesn't have a [ __ ]
chance in hell
that's what made you oh my God
poor little bastard
all right that's depressing
um so after we went golfing
we had a [ __ ] we had a great time and
uh my friends were all like really good
golfers and they all shot well and I
shot like a hundred and [ __ ] 90 on uh
nine holes but you know I had a good
time
I just like Smash in the [ __ ] Bowl
you know not like going up there and
trying to kill it I just like
hitting it further than it was supposed
to because I just have like that
baseball mindset like that's a home run
it went over the green you goddamn right
it did like [ __ ] Mark Maguire
um
anyway
um
we came back in this Resort that we were
staying at
like seven pools
all right
[Music]
hey yo I thought it was funny one of
them was the adult pool so I went to go
over there the first day I was like all
right I'm gonna go over to the adult
pool and oh my God
it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
it was just a bunch of oddish-shaped
tattooed white people just standing
there my people my peeps
just standing there
like
it looked like the [ __ ] like white
trash like Serengeti
you know when the water starts shrinking
up and all the animals like friend and
foe all have to [ __ ] sort of drink
next to each other just nobody was
swimming everyone was just standing
there
and they had like this mist spray that
they were spraying on them you know like
[ __ ] zoo animals and they would just
standing there
and I was [ __ ] die and laughing just
like thinking like the amount of uh
second marriages that were about ready
to kick off in that [ __ ] pool and how
there was probably more [ __ ] urine in
that pool than in like the kid pool so
we went over to the other side where the
families were at
and that pool was the complete opposite
Vibe it was [ __ ] great and they had
these this giant like water slide
and I'll tell you something underrated
going down a water slide where there's
no line
and it's also totally enclosed so you
can't go flying out the side if you're a
tub of [ __ ] and you held your arms in
the centrifugal force you know
sends you and your wedgied bathing suit
over the side
um
hoping that your fat back can cushion
The Landing
um
we went down that thing like three four
times
uh
uh I mean I was literally running up the
stairs to do it again like a little
[ __ ] kid I was like that was [ __ ]
awesome just like this is once again
some [ __ ] that I would never do so I
went golfing had a [ __ ] great time I
really
I really enjoyed it
um
and I gotta tell you man like golf is a
[ __ ] great game if you don't give a
[ __ ] and you don't keep score
if you care and you keep score it's so
[ __ ] it's kind of like everything
you know what I mean
you know what's weird I wonder if that
would work in your relationship
like if you just stop caring you
obviously still love the person but if
you just like stop giving a [ __ ]
and you just found it all funny you
found it funny that you know
whatever whatever the issue is in your
relationship the person doesn't take out
the trash they don't do the [ __ ]
laundry they uh you know
they didn't buy the kind of [ __ ]
cereal you like
and you just start to find the [ __ ]
humor in it
I wish the way I I go out on the golf
course I wish I could just walk around
in life like that instead of you know
like
giving a [ __ ] all the time
um
so anyway I don't know so I think I'm a
golfer Now ladies and gentlemen but like
I said I'm never buying clubs and I'm
Never Keeping score
um
you know
I like playing with like rented clubs
it's like I don't wanna
know I don't need this [ __ ] here take it
you know and then this is something else
I have to like book my phone and my
[ __ ] laptop I gotta buy new ones
every couple of years oh these these are
the ones
these are the ones
um
so anyway then we went back we went down
no I know we went we got breakfast after
we went golfing and we just laugh and
just having the best time then we sat
down
and we watched the Bills Dolphins
and uh I took the Dolphins verse he took
the bills
and the football gods were nice to meet
in the dolphin I should have filmed you
know the Dolphins like the Dolphins are
like an enigma you know
they never make the playoffs it seems
they don't even want to [ __ ] Super
Bowl since Richard Nixon was in office
but they like
you know they played really well against
I don't know I don't know about the rest
of the league but like
against teams that are supposed to be
good in the AFC East they they it they
always split the very least they're
gonna split
so um
yeah I took the Dolphins I was just
having a great time and I was like
teasing verzy because he took the bills
and the bills marched right down and
then you know just like jokingly
you know when the Dolphins tied it up I
just walked over
and I was hitting him with my napkin
making the sign of the cross and all
that just all that dumb stupid guy [ __ ]
just having a blast and then after that
we then went down the water slide and
then we all got in the car and we went
over to the uh
Arizona Cardinals game
against the Rams
and uh incredible seats they've hooked
us up so thank you to them
and um but I'll tell you what I realized
is I am actually I think I'm too old to
go to live sporting events
um
because I felt like I was at like a
Judas Priest concert it was so [ __ ]
loud
and it used to be like the crowd yelled
down at the field and now they literally
have like speakers pointed at you
like you're the problem like you're the
quarterback trying to give signals that
they don't want to hear and like
I gotta tell you something man like
I couldn't even hear the crowd the the
sound system was so [ __ ] loud I had
to put earplugs in and nobody else
around me
had like earplugs in so I was just going
like maybe I'm just too [ __ ] old for
this
uh uh that's our first ah what's this
guy whoever the [ __ ] he was just
screaming into a mic that's on 10.
and he'd be like they'd be like come on
everybody you know Make some noise and
then they just would play that Queen
[Music]
and no matter how loud you yelled you
weren't louder
than the pa the PA was so much more
[ __ ] louder
um
then uh than the fans were and I was
actually making me think you know I know
this is sort of the Billy old man
podcast here but like how it used to be
was the fans
knew when to get excited when to get it
going or there was someone in your
section could feel the crowd dying and
he would get you going and they were
like these class clowns in every like
section that would get it going and you
know back in the day when I first
started doing the road
what was cool about that was every city
had their own style and every city had
their own like humor like music like
music but you know there was a sound
that came out of this city a sound that
came out of that City Comedy was like
the same thing and they had the things
that they yelled the crowd would all
yell and you'd have to think like what
the [ __ ] why are they yelling that I
mean the biggest one that everybody
knows is like you know pot van sucks
you're like why do Ranger fans yelling
pot fan pot fan that is pot band that
guy [ __ ] retired you know all these
years ago
um you had to figure out what they were
yelling and why and you players would
touch the puck or something they'd start
booing and you'd have to ask somebody
next to you like why do you guys hate
that guy and they've been oh yeah
[ __ ] six years ago we cross-checked
our best player you know across the face
and uh he only got a two minute minor
[ __ ] like that now like the level of
like
um
I don't know I actually think like those
that loud DJ system
works the exact it has the opposite
effect
where rather than making the crowd get
louder I feel it makes them quieter
you know what I mean like why why you
mean I'm not going to sit there and try
to scream louder than a [ __ ] jet
landing at an airport
I'm just you know I don't know anyway so
I like stayed there for the half by the
second quarter I was standing outside
you know the area so I could get on the
other side of a wall from that that
[ __ ] Angus and Malcolm Young sound
system like the sound system at the
Arizona Cardinal game is [ __ ] no joke
uh it was too much for me in my old ears
you know I got tinnitus man I can't
[ __ ] sit there and get bombarded like
that so I ended up uh going out and I
was like watching the game on like a TV
and at that point it was just ridiculous
I was just like well why don't I just go
find a cigar bar and I found a cigar bar
and I left it like half time
you know because I was going to the
airport because I had to get on My Wife
and Kids
um
and we went to this
this great Cigar Bar
oh what the [ __ ] was the name of it they
had all these t-shirts I'm going to give
them a shout out on the next podcast
because I'll have it
um I'll find it right now anyway we go
there and they hook us up they put us in
the VIP room and I sat there and I
watched the game
with this guy who was a return all right
I accidentally hit [ __ ] stop when I
was trying to find I was searching for
the name of that Cigar Bar it's called
fine Ash f-i-n-e
uh a-s-h fine Ash cigars it was [ __ ]
phenomenal they treated us like kings
we're in like this VIP section and uh
I don't know if I if I if I
already said this or if this is some
[ __ ] I said when I accidentally hit stop
but I went in there and there was a
retired Dairy Farmer from uh Wisconsin
in there and we watched the game in like
you know 35 40 decibels and I got to
talk to him about farming and all of
that as I watched I watched Green Bay
Tampa I watched uh Seattle and the
Falcons and I watched uh
something else and I was like all right
I think this is the way
this is the way for me you know I'm just
an old [ __ ]
um but I want to thank everybody for
hooking me up with the tickets everybody
in Arizona
uh
the [ __ ] am I doing you guys want to
hear what my picks for last week I
picked the Dolphins minus four and a
half I picked the the the uh the
Cincinnati Bengals
I picked those guys because I was like
you know what are the [ __ ] odds
you know the Jets gonna win two games in
a row and Joe burrow who almost made to
the Super Bowl was going to lose three
in a row
took that one I had the Bears minus
three that was a push and then uh
I took Seattle minus one
against the Falcons and I didn't know
Marcus Mariota was playing
um
not saying I would have picked the
Falcons I probably would have just
stayed away from that game but anyway
two all in one after going Owen for the
week before and two and two so I'm still
behind the eight ball I gotta get caught
up you know me and varsie try to beat
the book every year uh at bet MGM so
we're starting a little slow but I think
we're gonna we're gonna get him more
information we have I think we're gonna
get him and lo and behold your Miami
Dolphins
are undefeated 3-0
atop the AFC East who would have thunk
it
um who would have thumped that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] fantastic I love it we
got a dog fight here huh you know those
bills out Buffalo out there right now
they don't like that sauce on those
wings
whatever people say
um
so anyway I don't have any of my
advertising or any of my questions so I
think I'm gonna have to [ __ ] hit stop
again
um I just picked up my truck my truck
just got serviced
you know the [ __ ] leaky bastard
and I got a
whatever the gaskets on either side of
the transmission are leaking so I'm
leaking a little bit of oil in the dry
on my [ __ ] garage it drives me nuts
so now I gotta find I gotta talk to this
guy
he's like you bringing the truck over
you're taking the transmission out I'm
like well if I take the transmission out
I I what am I going to bring it over in
and also like I don't have the tools to
[ __ ] do that but then these other
guys like well we can take it out for
you if you bring the truck over and it's
just this whole [ __ ]
this whole goddamn thing
every once on days like that I think
about selling my truck going like do I
really want to just
try and sit here and like
like my only goal with my truck one day
is I just wanted to be leak free
you know
like why the [ __ ] is it always leaking I
had the whole engine redone then I had
power steering problems
and then I had a radiator problem and
now I have these [ __ ] gaskets and I
swear to God it's like by the time I get
to the back of the truck the
differential will be the next thing that
[ __ ] leaks time I get back to the
truck I'm gonna be at the front of the
truck again because something else I
guess that's just how it is
I guess that's just how it is so um
anyway I guess I'm going to record the
next half of this podcast uh at the end
of the day I'm tomorrow we lock on the
film as far as all like the editing and
that then all I have left to do is color
it and put the right music in it I am so
[ __ ] excited for you guys to see this
thing it's been a long time coming and a
ton of work
and fortunately uh
I have
been working with some people that are
like [ __ ] geniuses
like the editor that we have on this
thing he made a couple of moves
on a few scenes that I was just like I
mean I don't know how do you even think
to do that and it just worked
[ __ ] magic so
um I'm really really really really
really
I'm probably more excited about this
movie than anything I've ever done
um including like stand-up specials
I think just because
I always did stand up and this is just
doing like a movie and something is
something that's different
um and I think I might have pulled it
off
oh freckles fooling them again fooling
them again
so uh
yeah so my days will be a little more
free I'll have time to take out my
lovely wife maybe go to the movies maybe
get a coffee
walk around holding her hand tell her I
love her you know doing that [ __ ]
that little stuff you know that keeps it
going
supposed to making you distant you know
next thing you know you're out
doing your laundry filling Melancholy
why is doing your laundry so [ __ ]
depressing
you know you know what it is it's the
stress I just remember the stress of
getting to the laundromat
you know
you know God forbid you had to do it on
a weekend and Jen just sitting there
you know and then you finally get a
machine and you're washing it and you're
trying to time it because the washers
get done so much quicker than the dryers
you're trying to figure stuff out you
see some other chick posting up and
you're like uh she's gonna win this
she's a woman you know it's a guy you
know you can be like oh you'll beat the
[ __ ] out of you you know you can't do
that with women
and then that feeling of Rage when you
would come back like two minutes after
your wash cycle stopped and someone had
taken your [ __ ] clothes out
um
oh my God the [ __ ] rage I would have
over that
that people would do [ __ ] like that I
mean I get it you know if you leave for
a while
but like sometimes I would come back
like a minute or two and they would
already be out and just somebody you
know and just wash my clothes and now
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
I tell you not to touch my hair and then
you hit it
oh who touched my 501 blues
um
but I remember like I just remember the
relief when you would actually get it in
the dryer
and your clothes were drying and you
were like oh my God in 50 minutes this
is going to be over
you know
the dryer is the one where you gotta
want you got to watch for the thieves
you know people stealing [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
breaking in and all of that crap um
anyways I'm just babbling here
um God damn it man I'll tell you what's
underrated a guy's weekend
and what's absolutely Priceless is a
wife that wants you to go do that [ __ ]
my wife loves that I go out and go do
that
you know and she goes off and does like
her uh sideways weekends with her
girlfriends you know
go up and [ __ ] drinking wine or
whatever
they do you know
am I like even doing a podcast anymore
I'm just [ __ ] like
I I got so much [ __ ] I have to do today
like my brain is [ __ ] all over the
place I'm gonna stop this thing here I
don't know why I always tell you guys
this I should just edit this part out
stop this here and then I gotta do my
whole day when I come home tonight I'm
gonna record the last half hour with
your questions and the advertising and
all that [ __ ] and uh that's it but I
feel you know recharged going on that
weekend very very [ __ ] underrated and
underrated going down a water slide at
54 years of age
is uh
it was it was [ __ ] amazing I was
literally grinning ear to ear running
back up the steps
like I was [ __ ] eight all right I'll
talk to you guys in a few well maybe not
maybe I'll just plow on through because
the Reeds came through by the way guys I
I will tell you if you're young and you
don't your ears don't ring non-stop I
cannot recommend highly enough that you
start wearing earplugs because
everything from sporting events to
nightclubs to movies to those stupid
[ __ ] things you guys are sticking in
your ears those little straw things that
are coming out like those things
are really doing massive amounts of
damage to your hearing and I know I
sound like an old man but like I was
young once and my ears didn't ring and
now they do and I'm telling you you
don't want this [ __ ] it [ __ ] sucks
so uh I always make sure I have earplugs
with me
pop them in
you know just in case someone's
screaming first down I mean dude
literally it was going through my chest
and my chair was shaking it's like what
what are we doing here
this is [ __ ] bananas
um anyway okay Bill you made the point
all right I gotta blow through this
stuff okay here we go zip
break what up
uh do you know there are currently over
2.4 million podcasts in the world
including the one you're listening to
right now that's [ __ ] insane uh and
it takes a team of people to help bring
these podcasts together needless to say
well how many McDonald's are there
it's probably a lot more than that right
uh needless to say Well then why why are
you saying it uh hiring the right people
for these roles is important and whether
you're hiring for a podcast or for your
growing business there's only one place
that makes it easy zip
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com zip
[Music]
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates
up with your job you can easily review
uh these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply
additionally zip
has a complete Suite of tools that makes
it easy to filter review and rate your
candidates four to five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first date so if
you're a fan of this podcast and you
want to try yes
for free today you need to recommend you
need to remember our special URL
ziprecruiter.com
once again that's zip
dot com slash Burr b-u-r-r zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is everybody
indochino
uh finding the perfect suit is
impossible
but finding a suit that's perfect for
you is simple thanks to indochino
finding the perfect suit is impossible
it's impossible
no one's ever done it
uh choose your favorite fabric
that's a wild to me finding the perfect
suit is impossible but finding a suit
that's perfect for you is simple
thanks to indochino
I see what they're doing there like
listen man this suit's not gonna be
perfect but it's going to be perfect for
you that's like a [ __ ] pimp line
all right shoes you [ __ ] indochito
getting all [ __ ]
got a fur coat no shirt on for this
[ __ ] read uh choose your favorite
Fabric and customize every detail to
find the look that's perfect for you
submit your measurements online or get
measured in store for a custom made for
you fit at an incredible price and with
their fall collection featuring new
colors and premium Fabrics you'll be in
style all season long every indochino
suit is made just for you it's tailored
it's a tailored experience at a great
price design a look that suits you
perfectly from the fabric to the cut
shop there Made For You suits starting
at just four four nine
and premium dude I got a [ __ ]
Oldsmobile Cutlass with a 449 in it 449
dollars in premium fitted shirts
starting at just 89 you can fine tune
every detail lapels Linings Monograms
and more get a premium personalized
wardrobe without spending a fortune shop
Custom fitted shirts casual wear out
aware in MOA uh design your perfect suit
with indochino to get fifty dollars off
any purchase of 399 or more
use promo code Burr Burr indochino.com
that's
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com it used to be hard
to find a perfect suit but I can find
the perfect suit for me promo code Burr
b-u-r-r
did you love those old songs
like that was like a hit song
you know
you didn't have to sing back in the day
about how you [ __ ] a [ __ ] is that what
kids do nowadays
yo
I'ma tell y'all how I [ __ ] a [ __ ] uh
um
[Music]
oh you know like I said
when I grew up
the guys were dressed like women wore
makeup and sang about the devil it was
just as [ __ ] stupid it really was it
was just as [ __ ] stupid
um but you know the way we did our
stupid things you know there was some
[ __ ] metaphors the innuendo no I'm
kidding no but back in the day like to
make like a hit song
you know
you sing the Mississippi am I yes I yes
s-i-p-p-i it used to be so hard to spell
it used to make me cry
like that was like a hit people like
knew that song or yes we Have No Bananas
we Have No Bananas today we string beans
in this [ __ ] and some other stuff and
this stuff right sorry that's the adult
explicit version
that's like just some [ __ ] guy was
walking down the street no that's not
true those were bad songs
because when you really listen to some
of the great songs though written back
then they're still timeless
like one of my favorite ones was Louis
Armstrong
sang this song I guess I'll get the
papers and go home
and it just I know I probably talked
about this before in the podcast but
nothing I've ever heard ever summed up
the emptiness
like after you're done crying after
you're out of a relationship
but then you're trying to like put your
life back together like what did I used
to [ __ ] do
before I was even with that person and
this song is just like a guy right in
that moment
I mean like I get the lyrics for you I
can remember I was like I guess I'll get
the papers and go home
like I've been doing ever since we've
been apart
I get some something something
from reading about someone else's Lonely
Heart
I wonder if you get the papers too and
if you feel is melancholy as I do
so until you're in my heart again
never do me wrong I guess I'll get the
papers and go home yeah I guess I'll get
the papers and go home
I don't think I've ever listened to that
song without just [ __ ] laughing
wait I guess
I'll do a better version here
I guess I'll get
the papers and go home here it is
why don't I just have him say no yes I
guess I'll get the papers and go home
like I've been doing ever since we've
been apart I get some constellation when
I read of someone else's
I wonder if you get the papers too and
if you feel is melancholy as I do baby
till you're in my arms again never more
to roam oh we [ __ ] around on her I
guess I'll maybe not roam around with
the papers I guess I'll get the papers
and go home
that's all it is and then he just sings
it again
that's all you had I don't know what was
my what what the [ __ ] was even my point
in doing that
sorry that's like three awful minutes
that you're never gonna get back all
right [ __ ] rickshaws
all right well there was a guy last week
I think it was an expat living in Hong
Kong or something
or somebody [ __ ] with me was saying
you could make more money pulling a
rickshaw than he could
you know trying to get a job in the
field that he has his degree in from
college there from the college there
um so it says [ __ ] rickshaws hey Billy
Freckle tank
was listening to the podcast from this
week and became filled with rage as soon
as you started reading the written in
about the dude with the double major who
wanted to be a rickshaw driver
he then says [ __ ] those guys exclamation
point all right I thought you were mad
at me he said I was in New York this
past summer with my wife and my daughter
or maybe these are the pedal guys
and they just call them rickshaw's
the guys are right about you say uh we
were going to to a play 1.2 miles away a
bunch of those rickshaws were tooling
around playing music so I figured that'd
be a fun trip for my daughter obviously
I knew I'd be paying a premium for the
air quote experience but going a mile
away I didn't think twice about it
almost [ __ ] my pants when we got there
and the guy said 140 without the tip
wow then the thieving [ __ ] pointed to a
sign that was hidden by a canopy on the
stupid Rickshaw where it states that
there's a 15 dollar per minute rate or
whatever it was
if I had known that I would have been
whipping his ass like the jockey riding
Seabiscuit
of course maybe all those guys and gals
are a union made up of double major
graduates
that are saddled with student loans that
need to be paid back love the podcast go
[ __ ] yourself I didn't know it cost that
much money
did it have to do with the fact that you
also had like four people so there you
know it's a lot more weight
140 bucks Jesus Christ there should have
been some champagne there huh all right
I I I I understand that I can go with
that sir uh things I can't have because
of my spouse
on the September 19th Monday Morning
podcast oh we were talking about yeah if
you weren't married what would you buy
you asked what what we want but our
partners won't let us have I didn't
quite say it like that it's like you
know this [ __ ] I could buy but I I want
my kids
you know to be okay I want to be able to
leave my kids something
um all right here's something this
person wants to have but he says his
spouse or she says her spouse won't let
her mine is a tattoo
as a kid watching sports I thought the
players with them look cool as hell and
wanted to have them on myself they are a
true passion of mine and I have read
countless anthropology books art Theory
books and watch documentaries out the
ass I don't just want them because they
look cool all right well that's how you
started it but now that you're like
you're really into it well you know
what's great about that you probably put
some thought into it it would maybe have
a cool looking [ __ ] tattoo rather
than just drawing all over your body
this dumb ass [ __ ]
um
but then again the average person isn't
that bright so if you're not that smart
you're not going to come up with a cool
idea right
anyway
that's why I never got a tattoo I'm too
[ __ ] stupid I would be like well I
got freckles why don't you color them in
and make like a cheetah and it's holding
like a Budweiser can
and it just says you know I do
you want that on your shoulder yes I do
if I could become a professional a
professor in tattoo anthropology and
tattoo art Theory I would that would
actually be fascinating if you actually
became that and you had no tattoos
um you'd be like a sports writer saying
what's wrong with the team and he can't
even throw a [ __ ] ball oh by the way
I was convinced I saw Bob Ryan at the
airport he had a hat on with a mask
and I'm going dude that's Bob Ryan
that's Bob Ryan but he's like I don't
think that's him we Googled him and all
of this [ __ ]
and finally just walked up to him I was
like are you Bob Ryan and he was like
this old guy and he got like all freaked
out I'm like sorry sorry I thought you
were a sports writer
um anyway
this guy continues on now I know they
are a perm now I know that they're
permanent and so I am not going to just
get some random flash work from an
apprentice in their kitchen for the [ __ ]
of it I'm going to go to a professional
artist who I have done done thorough
research on who I trust
and with portfolios I love
I also won't mess up my career as I do
cancer research and can cover them up
with my lab coat the only reason I
haven't gotten them is my fiance is a
hundred percent against it she doesn't
like change so I get that me saying I
want to permanently decorate my body is
hard for her to take we have been
together for 10 years since we were 14
so I didn't have the opportunity to get
them before we started dating she claims
she would dislike them on me and says I
would look bad which is just her fear of
changing
uh
uh of of change talking I think
because we have friends and families
that are tattoo artists and she likes
their work she actually likes tattoos
bill just not when it comes to me
now I don't care that's kind of wild now
I don't care if the if other people
think I look bad they are for me and no
one else so [ __ ] whatever anyone else
thinks what everyone else thinks but I
care about her and her opinion she is
the love of my life and she means more
to me than any possession or tattoo
which is why I am marrying her the other
problem is that they that they will cost
thousands we want to have kids soon and
it's not like we are rolling in tons of
extra money
for me to use following my own selfish
dreams uh what do you think Bill should
I give up on my dream any advice from
you or the lovely Nia would be
appreciated go Eagles big win yesterday
beating the [ __ ] out of the commanders
and go [ __ ] yourself
um
there's a hard one for me to answer
because I don't have any tattoos
and I really like tattoos
uh
uh I really like the cool ones and I
also like the ones that are just a piece
I don't like sleeves generally speaking
because
I don't know they just
it's just a bunch of [ __ ] now where it
used to be I don't know
I know this is the old guy [ __ ] thing
as I open a liquid death to everybody
here on the podcast
advertising there
um
you know if a guy had a [ __ ] sleeve
he was a lunatic like I remember when I
watched Motley Crue
and they slowly got more and more
tattoos when I saw like Nikki I think he
got his sleeve first I was like oh [ __ ]
what did he do because that was
considered
absolutely an insane [ __ ] thing to do
right through like the 80s and in the
90s if you had an entire [ __ ] sleeve
you'd basically left Society
okay and if you weren't like dealing
drugs or a hit man or you had your own
[ __ ] shop where you could fabricate
[ __ ] you you weren't going to get a job
anywhere
maybe maybe counseling like addicts you
could you could get something like that
but now it's just like
um
you know I've been on the road I've seen
a couple like really really attractive
women that just have a sleeve and I
actually you know
a few that I've seen they do look cool
but like a lot of them just look like a
whole bunch of nothing like it doesn't
look like anything it's just like maybe
that's the point
um
I don't know but I I am a fan of like
the Bon Scott style tattoos well you got
one on your bicep you got one on your
forearm bicep and forearm and maybe the
top of your forearm too like Axel Rose
did like I kind of felt like
you sort of use your skin to frame the
tattoo so it like stands out whereas
like you know at that [ __ ] Resort we
were at
this guy came walking up and he was like
like the guy from Blink 182 Travis
Barker where he from his neck down to
his waist it was just all
tattooed
it's like he had on a tattoo shirt and
um
I couldn't tell what any of it was and
then there's also like then you can't
really like look at him and stare at him
it is a piece of art but then if you
look at him too long [ __ ] are you
looking it's just like I'm just trying
to figure out this you know beautiful
mind [ __ ] that you have all over your
body
um
I don't know he is I wouldn't give up on
the dream like maybe she would come
around to it uh
uh like here's what I would do what what
if you figured out what you wanted
and then you had somebody sketch it and
it looks really beautiful and then you
came home you said listen I'm not gonna
get it but if I were this is it what do
you think of this it's pretty cool right
and who knows
this is a thing too your fiance doesn't
like chains whether she likes it or not
[ __ ] changes
she's going to change and everything
[ __ ] changes you have kids and
they're going to change
you know
I don't think it's over I think you know
you just keep uh
you just keep I would I know there's no
there's no person in the world
worth giving up your dreams for
they just isn't
if you're with the right person you you
should be able to follow your dreams
right
that sounds like some stupid [ __ ] that
somebody would say on [ __ ] Instagram
and then people like this 100
oh my God yes I was just saying that the
other day
but it is true
but you also have to make some like
sacrifices so I I don't think you're
you're I think you're going to get a
tattoo at some point just maybe not
right now
all right and
um
maybe like that there's a way for you to
talk to her like over the years and just
be like you know something I really want
to do I've always wanted to do it I'm
excited I'm really into it and here's
what I want to get I mean look this is
going to look great
and uh you know
this stuff you want to do and I think
you should go do it so why can't I do
what the [ __ ] I want to do I I don't
think the dream is over
all right and uh that's it
congratulations on getting married and
starting a family it's the greatest
thing I ever did so I hope you have the
same experience all right man toys hey
Billy hi-hat longtime fan here you
recently asked guys
uh to send in their thing that they
would buy if they didn't have a family
and had the money it's simple a 2022
F-350 Platinum Super Crew
uh four by four I refuse to say four by
four single rear wheel setup and a 6.7
liter power stroke diesel engine it
would be all blacked out with a level
not a lift what's a level
I don't know what that is tell them I
gotta look that up 18 inch matte black
rims and a 35 inch uh Ridge Grapplers I
don't even know what that is I would
have all the high-end package bells and
whistles Max tow package fifth wheel
prep two you might be thinking well this
[ __ ] must have some pretty damn big
things if he needs a a truck that size
nope just a 20-foot boat and my current
F-150 that my current on F-150 tows
without breaking a sweat uh
but that's not what it's really about
now is it
keep doing what you're doing you funny
orange [ __ ] much love to you and your
family go [ __ ] yourself yeah I mean
I bought an F-250
you know it's not here yet
I just like trucks and I feel like if
you like trucks there's nothing wrong
with it you don't put anything in the
back if you just like trucks there's a
bunch of people that like sports cars
and buy [ __ ] really fast cars they
never take them to the track and they
don't race them so like what are you
doing
what are you doing you're [ __ ]
driving down the street behind a [ __ ]
Camry
um ladies lady listener Oh Lady Lady
lesna job advice assumptions
hi Bill my husband and I just saw you
perform live we love live we love the
show thank you your interactions with
the crowd are so funny and it really
shows your skills I know you dismissed
praise so you can ignore this if you
prefer but the sentiment still stands
thank you uh my husband and I have been
married for one year together for four
we have a somewhat significant age Gap I
am 27 he is 38. that's not so bad but it
has never been an issue between us or
our families my husband is very
respectful and loving to me and we are
both equally ambitious in our careers
and recreational Pursuits my husband is
an officer in the Air Force I work in
cancer research well look at you guys
that's a [ __ ] great combo and we both
com compete in power lifting
I am currently also
currently finishing a master's degree
you guys are goal-oriented people
is that the right how you say goal
oriented
um anyway uh the issue
uh when I attend my husband's work
events such as casual get-togethers or
formal parties the other wives
automatically assume I don't have a job
the first few times I brushed it off as
a as silly assumptions but it has been a
continuing Trend once at a work dinner
with these call with his colleagues a
few women began advising me on how to
apply for work I tried to change the
subject several times why don't you just
say I have a job
but they kept turning
it back to job sites where I could do
Reese or I could search
or companies that are known to hire
military spouses
after several minutes I interject that I
am in fact employed as a scientist
but I will keep their suggestions in
mind they looked embarrassed and stopped
oh my God that well you don't need me
that is the absolute
perfect response
I'm employed as a scientist but I'll
keep your suggestions in mind holy [ __ ]
oh my God
game set match
checkmate
whatever other [ __ ] expression uh
that's a wrap they looked embarrassed
and stopped I had arrived at the dinner
from work so I was in my business casual
outfit I thought that would be
sufficient enough to show that I just
arrived from work because who wears
buttoned up shirts at home this
phenomenon has been confusing to me I've
been working since I was 16 and I have
worked quite hard to get into my
profession my husband is supportive and
proud of my work in my work environment
I am respected by physicians and
scientists so I'm confused why this
keeps happening I am unsure if this is
an assumption based on my age my
husband's job or something else yeah I
think it'd be a little bit of all of
that
do either you or nia have any advice or
on funny things to say or ways to turn
the issue around I I can't come up with
anything funnier
or more of just putting a [ __ ] period
on it
I'm employed as a scientist but I'll
keep your suggestions in mind
oh my God that's it's perfect
there's literally no fat on that you're
doing the exact right thing yeah and I
bet you know something if they're old
you know they might think that you know
they might be jealous they might be just
it doesn't sound like they're being
[ __ ]
but um you know there might be something
of that like oh she's young you know he
just [ __ ] works and she stays home
and does nothing then my thing is if
that's what they think about you then
why would they tell you to go out and
get a job
you know
I think your husband just works with
weird people
but you know I don't know
I'll tell you this so I I can't come up
with anything better that you said
so I would just say that I mean if you
want to say something else you could
just maybe push the issue more just out
of curiosity you could just say you know
what's so weird I'm employed as a
scientist
I'm literally maybe walk around the
Applebee's I'm literally a [ __ ]
scientist
but every time I come to one of these
work events the women always assume
that I'm not employed
maybe you could just say that can I just
ask you a question what is it about me
the way I look and the way I'm dressed
that makes you think I don't have a job
no no no no no no no no
I'm not trying to make it weird I just
need to know because don't feel bad
you're not the first person who's done
this why why do you think I don't have a
job
because I do have a job not only do I
have a job I'm a scientist
which means I'm probably smart you can't
say smarter than you you can't say that
then you're a dick right
but you could do that maybe you could
just ask them because you have the
perfect response if you just want to
shut somebody down from asking you
you know
oh he's walking out the door here he's
got [ __ ] to do
um why
you know you have the perfect response
to shut them down but if you want to
find out why it keeps happening
which I hope you're just doing because
you're curious
I wouldn't do it because okay that's why
they think that so I'm going to change
this about myself [ __ ] that you're a
scientist and you're a power lifter
right
you got [ __ ] what'd you say two
degrees I mean you're killing it yeah
anyway you have you have the perfect
response if you're actually curious you
could just ask them why they say that
but at the end of the day like who gives
a [ __ ] maybe find it funny maybe you
could just play along oh is that where I
could find a job
oh my God you're you're what a blessing
you know I have this because I have this
[ __ ] job that I'm doing currently
right now where I'm a scientist
um all right I gotta get out of here I
have [ __ ] to do thank you guys for
listening thank you to everybody at the
Cardinals organization and bet MGM for
giving us an incredible weekend uh we're
gonna be doing more Live Events with the
anything better podcast uh in some
sports cities so I'll keep you guys
posted all right have a great couple of
days you bucks